en el primer vídeo de evolución les di
el ejemplo de la polilla moteada o del
abedul durante la revolución industrial
en inglaterra y vimos como antes de la
revolución industrial había muchas
polillas moteadas y algunas eran
obscuras y otras eran claras otras
licencias en fin pero cuando todo se
cumplió de hoy y no de pronto se volvió
menos probable que las polillas moteadas
que eran oscuras fueran capturadas por
sus depredadores y por otra parte la
probabilidad de que las polillas
moteadas claras se reprodujeran de una
manera exitosa disminuyó entonces las
características obscuras de las polillas
esta variante se volvió dominante y se
hubiera llegado después y vieras que
todas las polillas ahora son negras
seguro pensarías que estas políticas son
más genios parece que se las ingeniaron
de alguna manera para camuflajearse y el
punto que estaba haciendo allí es que no
hubo ninguna ingeniería detrás no hay
algo explícito en su adn
que diga que tenga que ser así sólo fue
un subproducto natural
de que
esta variación y en este caso algo de
esa variación fue seleccionado en este
ejemplo es bastante sencillo negro
blanco pero que hay de cosas más
complicadas por ejemplo aquí en esta
ocasión tengo fotos de lo que comúnmente
se conoce como la mariposa búho y lo
asombroso aquí y yo creo que es bastante
obvio tal vez no debería señalarte lo
pero sus alas parecen el ojo de un búho
si pongo por aquí en un pico si pongo
por aquí un pico y por acá otra de sus
alas o tal vez otra mariposa búho date
cuenta que parece que tuviéramos los
ojos o la cara de un búho parece que un
bote está viendo cierto y de igual
manera que si yo pongo por aquí un pico
y por acá otro de los ojos bueno pues
aquí tenemos a otro búho que parece que
te está viendo fijamente entonces la
pregunta es cómo es que algo tan bueno
como esto aparece aleatoriamente a lo
que me refiero es que puedes imaginarte
pequeños puntos blancos negros y grises
y aparece aleatoriamente
y bueno la respuesta es bueno hay varias
respuestas una es encontrar el por qué
existe este ojo o este patrón que parece
un ojo de un búho y esto aún no se ha
decidido estuve investigando un poco
acerca de esto en wikipedia todas estas
imágenes son de wikipedia y en wikipedia
dicen que hay dos teorías rivales aquí
aunque para nosotros los humanos nos
parece un ojo de búho esto dicen es un
señuelo quiere decir que cuando los
depredadores quieran comer y atacar a
una de estas mariposas bueno pues en
lugar de atacar el cuerpo que tenemos
aquí va a atacar directamente a este
señuelo que tenemos aquí que les llama
más la atención es decir que esto se ve
mucho más sustancioso se ve algo rico en
proteínas y para el depredador esto va a
ser una buena comida van a preferir esta
cosa grande y negra en lugar del cuerpo
de la mariposa y entonces van a tratar
de quebrar y morder esta parte de aquí
en lugar de morder el cuerpo de la
mariposa y bueno si muerden esto estoy
seguro que las alas
van a cortar un poco y eso va a estar
bastante mal pero el animal en sí va a
seguir vivo la verdadera mariposa que
está aquí va a sobrevivir ya lo mejor
podría reparar sus alas realmente no lo
sé de hecho no sé nada de la biología de
la mariposa búho pero bueno esa es una
teoría el argumento en contra es que si
este fuera el caso realmente tú como
mariposa preferirías a tener estos
puntos llamativos más alejados de tu
cuerpo un poco más alejados de lo que es
tu cuerpo tal vez en esta parte o tal
vez en esta parte de tal manera que
cuando algo muerdan este punto llamativo
que tenemos aquí va a lastimar mucho
menos a nuestra mariposa y date cuenta
que aquí es mucho más probable que bueno
muerda el cuerpo de la mariposa que si
ponemos este mismo punto en uno de los
extremos y bueno la otra teoría de por
qué existen este tipo de alas y la
teoría que de cierta manera es la que
más nos brinca es que cuando demos esta
mariposa pensamos que bueno se ve como
un búho
entonces a lo mejor esto es para
espantar a cosas que probablemente se
coman a nuestra amiga mariposa y en mi
lectura resulta que hay lagartijas que
les gusta comer este tipo de mariposas y
esas lagartijas probablemente no les
gusta estar rodeadas de aves o búhos
porque esos búhos se comen a las
lagartijas entonces esto funciona muy
bien puede ser algo disuasivo y en otro
ejemplo que encontré todo esto me lo
dijo wikipedia es que también este tipo
de lagartos se intenta comer a nuestras
amigas mariposas pero estas lagartijas a
su vez son comidas por estas ranas que
tenemos aquí y de hecho las alas de esta
mariposa se parecen un poco a los ojos
de esta rana y por lo tanto asustan a
los lagartos y bueno podríamos debatir
si es este caso o no lo es si éste fuera
el depredador y te quisieras esconder de
él podrías argumentar que bueno debería
de haber un poco más de verde en estas
alas pero ese no es el punto del vídeo
el punto del vídeo aunque la discusión
parece bastante divertida saber para qué
son útiles estos ojos vamos a decirlo
así
punta del vídeo es como apareció este
ojo y para eso me voy a preguntar qué
conjuntos de eventos permitieron que
esto pasara porque recuerda cuando
describe la evolución y sabes que en
todo el reino biológico existe la
evolución eso en un conjunto que su
mayoría de proteínas y todas estas
proteínas son codificadas por el adn y
voy a hacer futuros vídeos acerca del
adn pero el adn es solo una secuencia de
pares de bases ya sabes una secuencia de
estas moléculas adenina guanina citocina
timina y no sé tal vez pueda seguir una
adenina otras y tocina otra timina y así
seguir y seguir y seguir y voy a decir
mucho más acerca de esto en el futuro
pero la idea es que las proteínas son
codificadas por secuencias de estas
moléculas como base una mariposa que no
tiene un ojo en una ala y de repente ya
tiene un ojo a su ala que pasó en todo
ese proceso obviamente un cambio que
suele suceder
una mutación al azar ya sabes puede ser
que en algún momento está a cambio en
algún punto por una gm o no sé tal vez
está [ __ ] se eliminen qué sé yo pero lo
que voy es que esto no va a desarrollar
este patrón tan hermoso como es este ojo
cómo es que se forma este patrón
tan útil entonces como puedes explicar
con cambios al azar algo tan complicado
y esta va a ser mi explicación
obviamente yo no estado sentado ahí
viendo los miles o millones de años de
cómo surgió en estas mariposas búho pero
esta es sólo mi teoría de cómo la
selección natural explican este tipo de
fenómenos y para eso déjame bajar un
poco esta pantalla y vamos a pensar un
poco en las mariposas búho imagínate qué
tú en un inicio
tienes alas de este estilo tienes muchas
alas de esta forma no es un gran dibujo
pero bueno te puedes imaginar que es el
ala de una mariposa y bueno en ella no
hay patrones generales que hemos visto
antes hay una cierta variación
entonces por aquí hay un cierto pigmento
por aquí también por acá también esta
variación se debe a cambios al azar en
el adn y creo que todos podemos creer
esto la mayoría de estos cambios son de
cierta manera benignos oa lo mejor son
pequeños patrones o una cierta mancha en
un pigmento de un color distinto e
inclusive lo podemos ver aquí en las
mariposas búho si te das cuenta está la
en definitiva es distinta a ésta a la
que tenemos aquí lo que tienen en común
estas figuras es la forma de estos ojos
bueno no solamente esto es lo más
interesante también tenemos no sé por
ejemplo esta formación de patrones aquí
que me parece interesante otras otras
cosas pero la idea que quiero que
observes detrás de todo esto es que
tenemos un poco de variación y para eso
voy a bajar de nuevo mi pantalla y ahora
date cuenta de esto
imagínate que aquí tenemos un ala de una
mariposa y no sé de tal vez por acá
dibujó otra ala
de otra mariposa se me ocurre algo más o
menos así y por aquí voy a dibujar otra
de ellas algo más o menos así
perfecto y voy a suponer que esta tiene
una composición de pigmentos más o menos
así se vea algo así no sé se me ocurre
algo de este estilo y bueno están se me
ocurre que se puede ver algo así voy a
poner aquí un poco más de pigmentos de
no sé este color no sé tal vez podría
tener por aquí otros patrones y espero
que ustedes visualizando bien todos
estos son cuerpos de mariposas así que
por aquí tendría el cuerpo de mi
mariposa y bueno sus antenas por aquí
también tengo el cuerpo de mis mariposa
y bueno sus antenas y por aquí también
voy a tener el cuerpo de mi mariposa y
sus antenas todo esto está muy mal
dibujado pero espero que tengas la idea
al final todo esto es aleatorio pero
cuando están en un cierto ambiente a lo
mejor la teoría de que estos patrones se
deberían de ver como un cierto ojo se me
ocurre es que tuviera este patrón de
aquí de una manera aleatoria y no estoy
diciendo que algún patrón sea mejor que
otro
tal vez estas dos mariposas fueron
encontradas y se las comieron sus
depredadores y tal vez eso fue lo que
pasó cierto todo es probabilístico no sé
a lo mejor esta amiga mariposa que
tenemos aquí tiene un 1% menos de
probabilidad de ser depredada porque
cuando un depredador ve en esta pequeña
mancha que tenemos aquí se le asemeja a
un ojo un ojo un poco confuso e intenta
no meterse con ella así que mejor va en
contra de esta que tenemos aquí y es por
eso que esta pequeña probabilidad que a
lo mejor estás pensando ok que puede
hacer ese 1% pero cuando juntas este 1%
de cientos en miles y miles de
generaciones de repente esta
característica va a empezar a dominar
simplemente porque va a ser menos
depredada menos depredada con bueno una
frecuencia de un 1% ahora a lo mejor
esta amiga que tengo aquí tiene una
mancha similar aquí algo muy parecido
qué bueno va a ser una mancha que se
asemeje al ojo pero está más pegada a su
abdomen y esto puede ser desfavorable
porque a lo mejor algunos depredadores
se espantan por esta concentración que
tengo aquí por este pigmento pero tal
vez ésta les haga ver que si es un
insecto y ojo insisto no estoy hablando
todavía de estas mariposas que tengo
aquí donde tenemos este patrón que ya
está muy desarrollado y muy avanzado o
sofisticado
estamos en un escenario donde la
concentración de pigmento que aparecen
es completamente aleatoria entonces
vemos que las mariposas que tienen la
concentración de pigmento alejada de su
abdomen no se las comen y bueno tal vez
está que está a cerca del abdomen los
depredadores piensan que realmente si es
un insecto y se la comen de hecho esto
sería una mala característica lo que va
a pasar es que esta amiga que domina
entonces va a dar bien a una población
en donde empieza a ver mucha variación
pero están va a tener una mayor
probabilidad de pasar sus
características
quiero dejar muy claro este punto esto
no sucede en el transcurso de la vida de
un animal no es que esta mariposa de
cierta manera haya experimentado algo y
de alguna manera pase ese conocimiento a
sus hijos no lo que sucede es que su adn
tiene una variación que al final resultó
ser más útil o que le da mayores
probabilidades de sobrevivir y de
reproducirse y entonces sus hijos se van
a ver de esta manera y van a empezar a
dominar en la población así que déjame
poner por aquí otras mariposas y por
aquí otra de ellas tal vez se vea esta y
algo así tiene esta área un poco más
punteada tal vez ésta tenga también aquí
una área más punteada pero tenga algunos
puntos por acá no se empieza a ver
variaciones en este patrón puedes ver
que de cierta manera la variación está
explotando y bueno quiero ser muy claro
y no usar verbos activos porque todo
esto se realiza con un proceso de
sentido común es un proceso donde todo
cambia los cambios que son los más
apropiados son
que harán que un organismo tenga una
mayor supervivencia y la siguiente
generación tendrá esa característica
pero también habrá variación en esa
misma característica y tal vez en esta
generación esta sea nuestra mariposa
indicada porque a lo mejor estas otras
dos tengan características muy similares
a las características anteriores pero
ahora que están compitiendo entre ellas
está sea capaz de reproducirse un 1% más
que bueno esta mariposa y esta mariposa
entonces nuestra siguiente generación se
va a ver más o menos así voy a decidir
que ahora en esta amiga representa la
mayoría de la población o bueno puede
ser que se combinen las tres
características y se reproduzcan y se
mezclen no sea esto puede ser un sistema
muy complicado pero bueno para hacerlo
más fácil vamos a pensar en esta amiga y
esta amiga va a representar a la mayoría
de la población y bueno van a salir a 44
mariposa aquí y ojo cuando digo esta
amiga mariposa me refiero a la
información genética de esta amiga
mariposa al menos a la parte
está relacionada con sus alas y después
empieza a ver variación en ellas a lo
mejor una de estas no sé se me ocurre
algo así tenga estos puntos por aquí y
después tenga algunos puntos algo así
alrededor o tal vez alguna de esta no sé
se me ocurre que regrese algunas
generaciones anteriores y bueno de hecho
esta va a quedar fácilmente eliminada
puede pasar esto y no sé a lo mejor esta
de aquí tenga un patrón muy similar a
esta no sé se me ocurre algo así y tal
vez ésta no tenga puntos no sé a lo que
voy con todo esto y creo que estás
entendiendo muy bien esta idea es que
esto no sucede de la noche a la mañana
estos cambios pueden ser muy graduales y
suceden a lo largo de miles de
generaciones
cuando hablamos de miles de generaciones
o millones de generaciones incluso este
1% de ventaja puede ser muy
significativo y cuando acumulas estas
variaciones en un largo periodo de
tiempo puede ser que obtengas patrones
muy complejos y complicados
como este que tengo aquí y es que
solamente quería explicar esto porque a
veces las personas dicen ok te puedo
creer un poco el caso de la polilla
volteada o incluso los ejemplos de los
antibióticos o las bacterias o la gripa
porque todos esos ejemplos suceden en
tiempo real pero como puede suceder algo
tan complicado como es esto que tenemos
aquí y es que aquí está el punto clave
creemos que todo esto es muy complicado
porque lo podemos ver en nuestra vida
diaria pero tal vez si ves la estructura
de una bacteria o de un virus y cómo
operan pueden ser mucho más complicado
que este diseño de hecho la razón por la
que estoy usando este ejemplo que tengo
aquí es justo por eso porque es un
ejemplo bastante simple en oposición a
explicar el metabolismo de un cierto
tipo de bacteria y como éste cambia o
cómo se puede volver inmune a la
penicilina o algo más pero quiero dejar
esto muy claro estos patrones tan
complejos a los que me refiero no
aparecieron de la noche a la mañana
que hayamos tenido una mariposa
completamente rosa no sé se me ocurre
algo así y entonces de repente tenga un
hijo y sus alas se vean justo como estas
alas que tengo aquí no esto sucede en
periodos largos de tiempo aunque a lo
mejor haya cambios hormonales raros que
hagan esto pero no me meteré en eso es
posible pero con lo que quiero que te
quedes es la idea de que esto no sucede
de la noche a la mañana quise hacer este
ejemplo porque entre más ejemplos veamos
nos hará más claro que esto es un
proceso pasivo y de hecho es muy
interesante ver lo que nos rodea
observar la forma que tienen actualmente
nuestros ecosistemas y luego pensar con
detenimiento en las razones por las que
pudieron haber surgido x oye organismo
de ciertas características y pensar qué
es lo que las hace útiles que provocó
que las seleccionarán por ejemplo es
posible que se seleccione alguna
característica aunque ésta se presente
después de la etapa reproductiva de un
organismo y no lo sé probablemente no al
menos que esto afectará la reproducción
para el siguiente
yo por ejemplo podrás decir bueno la
característica de cuidar a tus hijos
después de tus sueños' reproductivos es
algo que no se seleccionarían porque
sucede después de la edad fértil pero
piensan un poco más podría de hecho
seleccionarse y ayudar a que tus hijos
se reprodujeran por otra parte vemos
muchas enfermedades que se presentan
después de la etapa en la que podemos
tener hijos y cuidar de ellos una vez
que llegamos a los 50 oa los 60 la
incidencia de enfermedades aumenta
exponencialmente en comparación con
cuando somos jóvenes esto es en parte
porque la selección natural no siempre
llega a afectar las o digamos a
seleccionar en contra de ellas si se
manifiestan después de una cierta edad
después de eso ya no afectan a nuestra
capacidad de reproducirlos y también ya
criamos a nuestros hijos y ahora ellos
se pueden reproducir entonces lo que
sucede en este punto ya no es
seleccionado de cualquier manera espero
que este vídeo te haya dado un poco más
de matices sobre la evolución y quiero
hacer varios vídeos sobre
porque realmente quiero dejar muy claro
que esto no es algo que aparezca
espontáneamente esto es algo que sucede
en milenios y leonés y es muy
gradualmente